OK.
In a much awaited decision, the Supreme Court
just moments ago decided seven to two that
Donald Trump can not ignore a subpoena of
his financial records sought by New York prosecutors.
And the wording that I selected to tell you
that is not trivial.
And I'm going to explain it to you momentarily.
So zoomed out.
This is a big legal defeat for Donald Trump.
At the same time, his lawyer is calling it
a victory in that he is saying now they can
fight this out at a lower court.
And yet Donald Trump is also Simon's simultaneously
going absolutely crazy on Twitter.
And we're going to walk through all of it.
So let's start with the decision itself.
There's some confusion because there were
actually two decisions made here.
And also the decision is about whether this
now goes back to a lower court to be fought.
So what the Supreme Court said today is that
the path is legally cleared for prosecutors
to seek Donald Trump's financial records at
the lower court level.
A lower court previously found that Donald
Trump is not immune from responding to subpoenas
because he is president of the United States.
That's really the big decision here, because
for a while, Donald Trump and his lawyers
and others have argued it's not just that
Trump is immune from indictment.
Donald Trump is immune from investigation
by virtue of being president of the United
States.
And therefore, he doesn't even have to respond
to a subpoena for his financial records.
What the court found in a seven to two decision
is that Trump is not immune from investigation,
and that's actually a really big deal.
However, this now means that it goes back
to a lower court.
And what Trump's lawyer is saying is, OK,
well, I mean, you know, framing it as positively
as possible.
Now we go back to the lower court to keep
working to fight these records from being
provided on other grounds.
And, of course, prevent them from going public.
And the second part of the Supreme Court decision,
Congress was also seeking Donald Trump's financial
records.
For now, the Supreme Court has said prosecutors
can seek Trump's records.
You've got to figure it out.
But Congress for now is not going to Trump
is not going to be compelled to provide financial
records to Congress.
So this is I mean, listen, if you want me
to to just give you the highlight, we're not
going to see Trump's taxes before the election.
Right.
We have four months until the election.
What has been decided is that on principle,
Trump can't just ignore the subpoena from
prosecutors.
But now it's going to be fought at the lower
court if indeed Trump has to provide his financial
records.
It's not going to be done public.
It will have to be kept quiet at least, and
certainly beyond the November election.
So if your idea was based on this decision,
we might see Trump's taxes before November
not going to happen.
Now, Trump is going crazy on Twitter.
He immediately started tweeting uncontrollably
as soon as this decision went public.
And I'm going to go through some of those
tweets.
Trump starting with, quote, The Supreme Court
sends case back to lower court arguments to
continue.
This is all a political prosecution.
I won the Muehler witch hunt.
That's the one that said it couldn't clear
Trump on obstruction.
I won the Mueller witch hunt and others, and
now I have to keep fighting in a politically
corrupt New York.
Not fair to this presidency or administration.
He's the victim.
He's the most powerful person in the world,
maybe.
And yet he's the victim.
Everybody's unfair to him.
He just beat you.
It's all just stacked against him.
Trump continuing with another tweet saying,
quote, Courts in the past have given broad
deference, but not to me.
Again, he's the victim.
He's being singled out.
The courts are singling him.
Everybody's just singling him out.
Poor Trump.
And then a three tweet rant where Trump said,
quote, We have a totally corrupt previous
administration, including a president and
vice president who spied on my campaign and
got Kayte.
I guess he met caught.
I got Kayte and nothing happens to them.
This crime was taking place even before my
election.
Everyone knows it.
And he had all our frozen stiff with fear,
one against the one, all against the federal
government.
And the Democrats send everything to politically
corrupt New York.
I'm struggling to pass the grammar which is
falling apart with everyone leaving to give
it a second, third and fourth try.
Now, the Supreme Court gives a delay ruling
that they would never have given for another
president.
This is about all caps, prosecutorial misconduct.
We catch the other side, spying on my campaign.
The biggest political crime and scandal in
U.S. history.
And nothing happens.
But despite this, I have done more than any
president in history in first three and a
half years.
There might be.
Are there six lies there are might there even
be seven lies or dStore?
I mean, it's it's crazy what is going on.
And again, if his lawyer considers this a
victory, why is Trump going so crazy?
But the important takeaway is Trump is not
immune from investigation.
That's good.
It's a good thing the court has clarified
that.
But we are not going to see Donald Trump's
taxes before November.
And we all need to accept that that is the
case.
The good news is we don't need to see Trump's
taxes to know he has to be removed.
Whether we see Trump's taxes or not, we know
that Trump has to be removed in November.
So this isn't going to complicate voting for
me.
If you understand what
I'm saying.